there's a new study from Yale University
the University of Florida and the
University of Maryland and what this
study says is that transitioning to a
single-payer health care system here in
the United States would save about four
hundred and fifty billion dollars per
year it would save the average family
$2,400 a year and it would prevent
68,000 unnecessary deaths representing
in total about a thirteen percent
savings in annual health care costs with
increased access now you all know that
I've talked a lot about Medicare for all
and sometimes my commentaries about
Medicare for all anger some people in
the audience and typically those
commentaries are ones where I make clear
that I support Medicare for all and I
believe it may well be the best system
but I believe that the practical
difficulties of making Medicare for all
a reality are often understated I'm a
realist
that's true and a lot of people hear my
realism and they call me a defeatist now
this is a realist show this is not a
show that gives you fantasies so we
discuss the difficulties of policy and
you might have noticed maybe you didn't
that congresswoman Alexandria Castillo
Cortez recently similarly said you know
even if Bernie's elected you don't just
wave a magic wand and get Medicare for
all she wasn't attacked for saying
basically the same thing as I did but
that's another story let's take some
time today to in a non hyper partisan
way think through this very good study
which shows that Medicare for all would
be cheaper and it would prevent a lot of
unnecessary deaths and let's apply it to
our thinking about health care all
together there's a great health care
scholar who you've maybe heard me
mention before he passed away not long
ago his name is who've a Reinhart okay
and in his writing ube would explain
that when you look at health care there
are essentially three factors to
consider cost access and quality okay if
you pick a certain health care cost and
imagine you say a hundred billion
dollars is our healthcare cost you can
then choose a balance between how much
access is there for a hundred billion
and how much quality is there for a
hundred billion so to make it visual
imagine you have a slider it said we
have a hundred billion dollars to spend
on healthcare and you have a slider and
you can either give that hundred billion
in health care spending to one person
right if you give the hundred billion to
one person you are very low access only
one person has health care but they're
gonna get everything they need for that
hundred billion dollars quality is going
to be absolutely huge or you go to the
other side and you say well let's give
five billion people coverage for that
hundred billion dollars in health care
spending and you can imagine how now
access has gone up to a hundred percent
but quality is going to go down you're
not if you split the hundred billion
among five billion people instead of
giving it all to one person the quality
of care is going to go down now that's
an extreme example to get us thinking in
this sort of three metric mode everybody
has health care so now imagine a
different slider we have a different
slider called 100% access okay in this
scenario everybody has health care but
now you've got a balanced cost and
quality right 100% access is fixed all
else being equal if you want quality to
be high with a hundred percent access
you're going to have higher cost if you
want cost to be low under 100% access
then you are going to have lower quality
right if five billion people get crappy
care you keep costs low to give five
billion people better care costs are
going to go up so I think you get the
idea these are the three metrics cost
access and quality and any healthcare
program this isn't even yet about
Medicare for all any system we have is
going to somehow balance cost access and
quality if you don't change the system
but you just give everybody access the
only way to get it to cost less
to reduce quality of care unless you fix
other things and this is what's at the
crux of the medicare-for-all debate we
say hey you know what we can increase
access and we can keep quality the same
or better well only if you deal with
cost if you don't deal with the cost of
the system costs will go up to keep the
same quality and to give more people
health care and so that's where you get
to a lot of the ways in which a program
like Medicare for all
can actually reduce cost without
affecting quality necessarily so you can
remove a lot of the middlemen that
inflate costs you can take away the
profit part for health insurance
companies which is actually relatively
low you can eliminate all these multiple
layers of medical billing and
bureaucracy and unnecessary medical
testing you can do all that stuff but
that's more of a gray area and the
biggest criticism of most Medicare for
all plans is not you know from this
ideological it's socialism perspective
that those are dumb critiques the
serious critiques of Medicare for all
are that most of the plans way too
generously assume massive cost cuts that
they claim won't affect quality in order
to get everybody access without costing
more and without sacrificing quality
that gets us to this new study this new
study says we could transition to
Medicare for all
we will save four hundred and fifty
billion dollars per year we will save
sixty eight thousand people from
unnecessary death and everybody will get
access so when we go to our three
metrics they are saying cost will go
down and access will go up they don't
say anything about quality so the
critique of this study is that it is not
realistic in terms of the quality of
care that will be provided this is not
my criticism this is the reality cost
access quality unless you can explain
here's how we reduce costs in order to
increase access without reducing quality
this is how it works these are the three
factors and studies that say you can get
massive savings just from making some
small tweaks
you're often only talking about a couple
percentage points and case in point this
study has been analyzed by the Economic
Policy Institute and the Economic Policy
Institute said the cost savings that are
predicted are on the high side this is
not a surprise to us so again am i
against a system like Medicare for all
know I'm for it I'm for it I'm for it
I'm for Medicare for all I'm in favor of
Medicare for all what I'm telling you is
if you want to increase access to 100%
which I do if you want to keep quality
the same or increase it which I do it
most likely is going to cost much more
than what any candidate is currently
claiming and that's okay we can say as a
society it will cost more in total but
you'll save premiums and co-pays we'll
separate insurance from employers so
people don't have to tie their insurance
to a job will reduce the cost per person
rich people will have to pay quite a bit
more in order to subsidize the system in
total it will cost more I'm okay with
that
I'm okay because I think we need the
same or better quality than what we have
now and we need 100% access I'm ok
paying more if that's what it takes but
we need to understand the reality of the
plans and a lot of the plans are
assuming if we switch to Medicare for
All American health care costs per
capita will drop from what they are here
to what Australia or Canada pay that's
not going to happen by making the small
tweaks that a lot of people are talking
about it's gonna require much much more
yes we've got to eliminate waste but to
match the per capita costs of Australia
and Canada eliminating wet waste just
isn't enough and we've got to figure
that out and we need to have answers
because I want a system like this I hope
that my analysis is making sense I want
to hear from you remember I'm for
Medicare for all if you're about to
email me and tell me how terrible it is
that I'm against it a followed the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me on
instagram at david pakman